GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN, THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON. WE WILL BE
HEARING EXACTLY ONE BILL TODAY,
AB 247 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI. WITNESSES TODAY ARE
ASKED TO LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY
TO TWO MINUTES, TWO MINUTES EACH
TO ENSURE THE COMMITTEE IS ABLE
TO COMPLETE TODAY'S AGENDA IN A
TIMELY FASHION, WE DO NOT YET
HAVE A QUORUM. WE WILL BEGIN AND
WE MIGHT. WE MIGHT WE DO. WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM, SO SEEING WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM, MADAM, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. NEWMAN. HERE.
NEWMAN HERE. OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI.
PRESENT CORTEZ. HERE. CORTEZ.
HERE. GLAZER GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS HERE. WILK EXCELLENT. A
QUORUM HAS NOW BEEN ESTABLISHED.
SO WELCOME, ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MURATSUCHI. YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. CHAIR. SENATORS, WE
HAVE A DEAL. AFTER TWO YEARS OF
WORKING ON AB 247, I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR BEING A
JOINT AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE.
TOGETHER WITH SENATOR GLAZER,
WHO INTRODUCED THE ORIGINAL
SENATE VEHICLE FOR THE SCHOOL
BOND NEGOTIATIONS. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK, ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE
FONG, CHAIR OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE IN THE
ASSEMBLY, WHO IS ALSO A JOINT
AUTHOR AND WOULD LIKE, WITH YOUR
PERMISSION, MR. CHAIR, TO ALSO
CO PRESENT THIS BILL AND I
BELIEVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORI
WILSON, THE CHAIR OF THE BLACK
CAUCUS, WILL BE JOINING US ALSO
AS A JOINT AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE. SO, AFTER, MANY,
NEGOTIATIONS, WE HAVE LANDED ON
THE FOLLOWING SCHOOL BOND, THAT
THE SPEAKER AND THE PRO TEM HAVE
AGREED UPON, THIS BOND IS
PROPOSING $3.3 BILLION IN NEW
CONSTRUCTION FOR SCHOOLS, 4
BILLION FOR MODERNIZATION, THESE
ARE ALL FOR K THROUGH 12, AND
WITHIN THE MODERNIZATION, THERE
IS $115 MILLION SET ASIDE FOR
LEAD REMEDIATION AND DRINKING
WATER AT OUR SCHOOLS. AND WE
ALSO HAVE A SET ASIDE OF $600
MILLION FOR CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION, A PRIORITY CHAMPIONED
BY THE PRO TEM, AS WELL AS $600
MILLION FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THIS BILL, THIS PROPOSAL IS
CENTERED ON CONSIDERATIONS OF
EQUITY. WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ACHIEVE THE GREATEST
GOOD FOR THE GREATEST NUMBER,
WITH THOSE WITH THE GREATEST
NEED. TO THAT END, THERE ARE
THREE MAJOR PROVISIONS TO
ADDRESS COMMUNITIES THAT, EITHER
HAVE THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGES OF
SOCIOECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS AND OR THEY MAY HAVE
LOW BONDING CAPACITY, THAT THEY
MAY HAVE LOW PROPERTY VALUES
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT, SMALL RURAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO, NUMBER ONE, THIS
BILL IS INCREASING THE MAXIMUM
BONDING CAPACITY TO QUALIFY FOR
THE FINANCIAL HARDSHIP PROGRAM.
THE FINANCIAL HARDSHIP PROGRAM
IS THE KEY PROGRAM TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS ABOUT SERVING DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE LOW BONDING CAPACITY
AND THE FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
PROGRAM IT ALLOWS FOR
TO SUPPORT
FOR THE MEASURE. SO PLEASE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE, YOUR NAME,
YOUR ORGANIZATION, YOUR
POSITION, PLEASE. MR. CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
MIKE WEST, ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, YURI
CALDERON. I'M THE NEW EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB 247, THIS BILL HAS SOME
VERY GOOD IN FUNDING
ENHANCEMENTS, THE SLIDING SCALE,
THE SET ASIDES, THESE ARE ALL
GREAT THINGS FOR OUR SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS, IN PARTICULAR,
THE SUPPORT THAT IT GIVES SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE AND
ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. AGAIN, YOU JUST NAME
YOU'RE GOOD, YOU'RE GOOD, YOU'RE
GOOD, NAME? ORGANIZATION
PHYSICIAN CHRISTINA MARSALIS. ON
BEHALF OF THE 19 COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT MAKE UP THE LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL CONSORTIUM IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHRIS REIF, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. NANCY
ESPINOZA, ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING OR CASH, WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORS, THE COAUTHORS
AND THE LEADERS OF BOTH HOUSES
FOR PROTECTING THE ACCESS OF ALL
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA TO THIS
CRITICAL PROGRAM, AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. IAN PADILLA WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CONSTRUCTION
MANAGERS, THE COUNTY SCHOOL
FACILITIES CONSORTIA, THE SCHOOL
ENERGY COALITION, AND ONE MORE
AND THE SCHOOL FACILITY
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, MARK MCDONALD ON
BEHALF OF THE ANTELOPE VALLEY
CONTRA COSTA, LOS ANGELES, SAN
BERNARDINO AND SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. SÐNG LARA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS ANDREA BALL HERE FOR
THREE ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION, WHICH IS A COALITION
OF 128 LEAS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. THE LONG BEACH UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR, AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND AUTHORS,
MICHELLE GILL, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR,
AND MEMBERS. JEFF VACCA,
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CARLOS ROJAS,
REPRESENTING THE KERN COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
OFFICE, AS WELL AS THE 46 SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN KERN COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE
. GOOD AFTERNOON. PATTY HERRERA
ON BEHALF OF THE CORONA-NORCO
AND SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON, ELLA
CONNELLY, ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND
UNIFIED IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS.
LINDA VASQUEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ANDREW MARTINEZ,
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. PAMELA GIBBS,
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. AND
WE SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. JUAN ALTAMIRANO
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
COAUTHORS ON THIS AND STAFF FOR
WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY ON THIS
ISSUE. IN PARTICULAR, WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE LANGUAGE THAT
WAS INCLUDED IN THE BILL RELATED
TO GREEN SCHOOLYARDS. SO WE WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND EVERYONE
ELSE FOR WORKING HARD ON THIS.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CAITLIN ZHANG,
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY DISTRICT ADVOCATES FOR
BETTER SCHOOLS, CALIFORNIA, IT
AND EDUCATION, AND THE SCHOOL
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. AFTERNOON,
STELLA JOHNSON, ON BEHALF OF
PASADENA CITY COLLEGE, EL CAMINO
COLLEGE IN SANTA MONICA. COLLEGE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, BELLA
KERN, ON BEHALF OF CLOVIS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND ELK
GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI. KATIE
HARDIMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. AND
SUPPORT, THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. DAN DONMOYER,
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. IN SUPPORT OF THIS
TRUE PARTNERSHIP. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, JOHN WENGER, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION, APPRECIATE THE SET
ASIDE FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
GETTING US CLOSER TO EQUITABLE
FUNDING FOR FACILITIES WE DO
SUPPORT. THE BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. KEISHA HUNT HERE
WITH NOSSAMAN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THREE ORGANIZATIONS CITRUS
COLLEGE, NORTH ORANGE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT, AND ALSO SOUTH
MAIN, MOUNT SAN ANTONIO, SCHOOL
DISTRICT, AS WELL A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. I'M SORRY, THEY CALL
THEM MOUNT SAC. THAT'S WHY I'M
GETTING CONFUSED. BUT IT'S MOUNT
SAC. BUT SAN ANTONIO IN MY
DISTRICT. THANK YOU. WELL DONE.
THANK YOU, NEXT, PLEASE. MATTHEW
HAAGA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION.
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
AND JOIN THE HOME BUILDERS WITH
COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE ON THIS
SIDE OF THINGS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LET'S NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION, WE SHOULD HAVE, I
THINK TWO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AS LEAD
WITNESSES. PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND YOU CAN COME TO THE TABLE.
AND EACH OF YOU WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES, IF YOU CAN HAND IT TO
THE SERGEANT, HE'LL BRING THOSE
TO US. AND EACH OF YOU HAS TWO
MINUTES. AND WELCOME ANY ORDER
YOU LIKE. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS NICOLE VANNUCCI. OH. I'M
SORRY. YEAH. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS NICOLE
GANASSI, AND I'M AN ATTORNEY
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES. PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN MORE THAN 30 ALLIED
EQUITY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND IMPACTED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE ON RECORD
AS OPPOSING AB 247 BECAUSE IT
UTTERLY FAILS TO MAKE ANY
MEANINGFUL PROGRESS ON EQUITY.
DESPITE WHAT YOU HAVE HEARD
TODAY, AS STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS
DEMONSTRATED OVER THE PAST 25
YEARS, CALIFORNIA'S UNIVERSAL
60% MATCH FOR MODERNIZATION
FUNDS HAS DELIVERED MORE THAN
FOUR TIMES AS MUCH STATE BOND
FUNDS PER STUDENT TO WEALTHY
DISTRICTS AS LOW WEALTH
DISTRICTS. EVEN WITH THE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP PROVISION IN
PLACE, AS WE EXPLAINED IN THE
LEGAL DEMAND LETTER THAT WE SENT
IN FEBRUARY, THIS SYSTEM IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BECAUSE IT
TREATS STUDENTS DIFFERENTLY
BASED ON THEIR WEALTH. EXCUSE
ME? BASED ON THE WEALTH OF THEIR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS. IF YOU
HAVE MORE LOCAL WEALTH, YOU WILL
GET MORE FUNDING FROM THE STATE,
WHICH VIOLATES WELL-SETTLED
EQUAL PROTECTION PRINCIPLES
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. OVER THE PAST FOUR
MONTHS, AS REFLECTED IN THE
CHART THAT WE HAVE PROVIDED YOU,
WE AND OTHERS HAVE REPEATEDLY
DEMONSTRATED THAT AB 247
PROPOSED POINT SYSTEM WILL DO
NOTHING TO REVERSE THE
REGRESSIVE DISTRIBUTION OF STATE
BONDS, NOR WILL THE MINOR
CHANGES TO THE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP PROGRAM, WHICH DO
NOTHING TO ADDRESS THE PUNITIVE
AND BURDENSOME NATURE OF THAT
SYSTEM. INSTEAD OF MAKING ANY OF
THE PROPOSED MEANINGFUL EQUITY
FIXES, THE CURRENT BILL DOUBLES
DOWN ON MAINTAINING A
DISCRIMINATORY SYSTEM THAT
DISTRIBUTES MOST OF THE FUNDING
UNDER THE CURRENT RULES AND ONLY
OFFERS A NOMINAL INCREASE IN
STATE MATCH DOLLARS TO HIGHER
NEED. COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE,
A SLIDING SCALE OF 60 TO 65% IS
NOT A MEANINGFUL EQUITY
ADJUSTMENT. THIS IS EQUITY IN
NAME AND NOT SUBSTANCE.
MOREOVER, THE BILL BEFORE YOU
DOES NOTHING TO CHANGE THE FIRST
COME, FIRST SERVE SYSTEM THAT
ADVANTAGES WEALTHIER DISTRICTS,
ACCORDING TO THE STATE AUDITOR.
IN SHORT, WE ABSOLUTELY NEED AN
EDUCATION BOND. BUT THIS BOND IS
NOT IT. WE NEED AN EQUITABLE
BOND, NOT ONE THAT SAYS TO LOW
WEALTH COMMUNITIES FROM DEL
NORTE TO SALINAS TO LYNWOOD TO
SAN BERNARDINO, THAT NO ONE
CARES IF STUDENTS IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES ARE EDUCATED IN
SUBSTANDARD FACILITIES. VOTING
YES ON AB 247 AS IS, IS VOTING
YES TO CONTINUE DISINVESTMENT IN
LOW WEALTH COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND UNNECESSARILY INVITING
LITIGATION THAT COULD COMPLICATE
SUPPORT FOR THE BOND, WE HAVE
PRESENTED AN EASY LANGUAGE FIX
THAT ADDRESSES THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE WHICH YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU. IT WOULD
PROVIDE THE WEALTHIEST DISTRICTS
A 5% MATCH BASED ON THEIR AMPLE
LOCAL RESOURCES, AND THE POOREST
DISTRICTS UP TO A 95% STATE
MATCH. YOU HAVE TIME TO FINISH
UP. SORRY. YES, PLEASE. YOU HAVE
TIME TO ADOPT THIS LANGUAGE
BEFORE JULY 3RD. WE URGE YOU TO
DO SO. THANK YOU, NEXT WITNESS,
PLEASE. MR. HARDY. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS GARY
HARDY, REPRESENTING THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE LEARNING INSTITUTE AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
BLACK SCHOOL EDUCATORS. AND ALSO
AS A MEMBER OF THE LYNWOOD
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD OF
EDUCATION. I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND COAUTHORS EFFORTS TO
MOVE TOWARDS EQUITY, BUT WE'RE
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR AN EVEN
GREATER INVESTMENT TO ADDRESS
THE SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES THAT ARE
FOUND IN SOME OF THE LANGUAGE IN
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM, EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY IS THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
TO JUSTICE AND PROPORTIONAL
FAIRNESS AND EDUCATION ROOTED IN
THE NATURAL LAW OF RIGHT, THAT
EVERYONE DESERVES AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LEARN AND GROW. OUR CURRENT
SCHOOL FACILITIES FUNDING SYSTEM
IS PERPETUATING DEEP ROOTED
INEQUITIES THAT ROB COUNTLESS
STUDENTS OF THEIR POTENTIAL
PROPERTY POOR DISTRICTS FACE
UPHILL BATTLE IN STRUGGLING TO
RAISE MATCHING FUNDS DUE TO LOW
PROPERTY VALUES, OFTEN THE
RESULT OF DECADES OF SYSTEMIC
DISCRIMINATION, UNDERINVESTMENT
IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THIS
CREATES A VICIOUS CYCLE WHERE
WEALTHY DISTRICTS, AS AREAS
EASILY CAN MODERNIZE SCHOOLS,
WHILE UNDERSERVED, UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES ARE LEFT WITH
CRUMBLING AND INADEQUATE
FACILITIES. THIS ISN'T JUST
UNFAIR, IT IS MORALLY
UNACCEPTABLE. THE QUALITY OF A
STUDENT'S LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
SHOULDN'T DEPEND ON THEIR ZIP
CODE. YET THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THE SYSTEM WE HAVE IN PLACE
PERSISTS. WE'RE SENDING A
DEVASTATING MESSAGE TO MOST OUR
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS THAT
THEIR EDUCATION AND FUTURE IS
SOMEHOW WORTH A WORTHLESS
CLIMATE CHANGE IS HOW IT'S ALSO
NOW EXACERBATING THESE
INEQUITIES, WHERE EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS ARE BATTERING OUR
AGING INFRASTRUCTURE, WITH
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES BEING
BEARING THE BRUNT OF THE DAMAGE
FROM UNBEARABLE HEAT WAVES TO
DESTRUCTIVE STORMS, THESE
CLIMATE RELATED INCIDENTS ARE
WIDENING THE GAP BETWEEN
WELL-RESOURCED AND STRUGGLING
DISTRICTS. I URGE THIS COMMITTEE
TO MAKE EQUITY THE CORNERSTONE
OF AB 247 AND ADOPT ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE. THAT MEANS THAT MEETS
THE NEEDS OF THE MOST IN NEED
DISTRICTS. THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT BUILDINGS, BUT ABOUT
JUSTICE, ABOUT OPPORTUNITY AND
CORRECTING HISTORICAL WRONGS.
AND WE MUST CREATE A SYSTEM
WHERE EVERY STUDENT, REGARDLESS
OF BACKGROUND OR COMMUNITY
WEALTH, HAS ACCESS TO SAFE,
MODERN LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS
THAT INSPIRE AND ENABLE THEIR
SUCCESS. BY IMPLEMENTING AN
EQUITY FOCUSED PROGRAM, WE CAN
SEND A POWERFUL MESSAGE TO ALL
OUR STUDENTS FUTURE MATTER
EQUALLY AND JUST IN CLOSING, I
KNOW I'M KIND OF RAMBLING
BECAUSE I WAS JET LAGGED. I FLEW
IN FROM NEW YORK A COUPLE HOURS
AGO, JUST WANTING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IT'S CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND THAT EVEN IN
LYNNWOOD, WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
AS A SCHOOL BOARD, WHETHER OR
NOT WE WOULD PUT A BOND ON THE
BALLOT, WE HESITATE TO DO SO
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO FURTHER
TAX OUR OUR OVERLY COST BURDENED
DISTRICT. WE ALSO KNOW THAT IF
WE DON'T PUT A BOND ON THE
BALLOT, THEN WE'RE SORT OF LEFT
TO OUR OWN DEVICES TO REALLY
ADDRESS OUR AGING. I HAVE TO ASK
YOU TO FINISH UP. SO AGAIN,
JUST, JUST URGING THE AUTHORS OF
QUALTRICS TO CONSIDER MORE
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE AROUND
EQUITY TO ENSURE THAT THE
DISTRICTS THAT NEED THE MOST
SUPPORT RECEIVE THE SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED. THANK THANK YOU, MR.
HARDY. OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE. YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION,
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS RICHARD MARCUSON,
REPRESENTING THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION, THE PLUMBING,
HEATING, COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA, THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS OF THE AMERICAN FIRE
SPRINKLER ASSOCIATION, THE
INDEPENDENT ROOFING CONTRACTORS
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE TWO POINTS
GIVEN TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
ADOPT A PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT.
PLA'S COST SCHOOL DISTRICTS 15
TO 18% FOR CONSTRUCTION COST.
IT'S NOT NECESSARY IN THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WELCOME. HELLO. A LITTLE TALLER,
HELLO, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MY NAME IS SEDALIA
KING WITH CATALYST CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI, EVERYONE.
ALLISON OSORIO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR
FUTURE OF LEARNING IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. RAQUEL MORALES, ON
BEHALF OF US WEST IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION, ANY TWEENERS DO
WE HAVE ANY TWEENERS HERE,
SEEING NONE. LET'S COME BACK TO
THE DAIS. COLLEAGUES, QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS? I JUST WANTED TO
ASK THE AUTHORS IF THEY WANT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE ABOUT
EQUITY, AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY
THAT, PARTICULARLY WHEN WE LOOK
AT SOME OF OUR FACILITIES IN
PLACES LIKE SOUTH CENTRAL,
PLACES LIKE INGLEWOOD, WE SEE
HOW THERE HAS NOT BEEN ANY TRUE
INVESTMENT IN THOSE CAMPUSES,
WHICH I THINK DOES ADD TO THE
LEVEL OF ABSENTEEISM. WE WANT TO
CREATE CENTERS THAT DRAW OUR
STUDENTS, THAT INSPIRE OUR
STUDENTS TO COME BACK INTO THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM. BUT I AM
VERY CURIOUS ABOUT THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED ABOUT
EQUITY. AND WHERE IS THERE,
WHERE DO THESE TWO, PROPOSALS
INTERSECT, AND HOW ARE YOU
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION ON
THIS? SURE, SO FIRST OF ALL,
THANK YOU, SENATOR, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE ENGAGED WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES, AS SOON AS THEY
ISSUED THEIR, LETTERS, RAISING
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SCHOOL BOND,
AND LET ME JUST SAY, YOU KNOW,
IT IT JUST BREAKS MY HEART THAT
TO HEAR SOME OF THE OVER THE TOP
RHETORIC THAT THEY'RE USING, YOU
KNOW, WHEN THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
WEALTHY DISTRICTS, THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT DISTRICTS LIKE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED, YOU KNOW, WITH
90 CLOSE TO 90% UNDUPLICATED
STUDENT COUNT. THE DISTRICTS
THAT PUBLIC ADVOCATES IS TRYING
TO FOCUS ON ARE THE DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE THE LOWEST BONDING
CAPACITY, WHICH IS WHY I STARTED
OFF BY FOCUSING ON THE
PROVISIONS TO INCREASE THE
DISTRICTS THAT QUALIFY FOR UP TO
100% STATE FUNDS TO COVER THEIR
SCHOOL FACILITY FUNDS. SO, UNDER
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S PROPOSAL, THEY
WANT, YOU KNOW, THEY WANT
DISTRICTS LIKE LYNWOOD AND
MOSTLY SMALL RURAL DISTRICTS TO
BE ABLE TO GET, YOU KNOW, MOST
IF NOT ALL OF THE BOND FUNDS
THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED IN THIS
MEASURE. AND I WOULD SAY THAT,
YOU KNOW, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT,
I, YOU KNOW, IF OUR GOAL IS TO
SERVE THE GREATEST GOOD WITH THE
GREATEST NUMBER, THE GREATEST
NUMBER OF SOCIOECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS ARE IN
THOSE DISTRICTS THAT THEY'RE
CALLING WEALTHY DISTRICTS LIKE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED, LIKE
OAKLAND UNIFIED, LIKE LONG BEACH
UNIFIED, YOU KNOW, DISTRICTS
THAT LINED UP IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
THEY STAND TO BENEFIT FROM THIS
SCHOOL BOND. I ABSOLUTELY
RESPECT, YOU KNOW, PUBLIC
ADVOCATES AND, YOU KNOW, WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO. AND WE TRY
TO THIS IS LIKE EVERY, STATEWIDE
INITIATIVE. THIS IS A
COMPROMISE. IT'S A COMPROMISE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
FUNDING TO THE LARGE URBAN
DISTRICTS LIKE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED, LIKE OAKLAND UNIFIED,
YOU KNOW, THAT HAVE THESE LARGE
POPULATIONS. AND, SENATOR, YOU
KNOW, I MEAN, WE BOTH REPRESENT
LOS ANGELES. YOU KNOW, I THINK
WE KNOW THAT IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE, LOCAL AND STATE
FUNDS, YOU KNOW, GET SPENT,
INVESTED IN COMMUNITIES LIKE
SOUTH LOS ANGELES, YOU KNOW,
THAT IS ON THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT IS ON THEIR SCHOOL BOARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE SERVING
ALL OF THEIR, THEIR, THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS. BUT THE, THE, THE
BASIC ARCHITECTURE OF THIS
SCHOOL BOND, STATEWIDE SCHOOL
BOND MEASURE IS TO LET LOCAL
DISTRICTS IDENTIFY, YOU KNOW,
THE PRIORITIES AND THE STATE
MATCH THE LOCAL LOCALLY DEFINED
PRIORITIES, I YOU KNOW, I HOPE
THAT HELPED ANSWER THE QUESTION.
IF I COULD ECHO, PLEASE, AND
THEN WE PART OF MY TESTIMONY WAS
NOTING THAT WE DO PROVIDE
GREATER SUPPORT TO DISADVANTAGED
AND LOWER WEALTH COMMUNITIES.
AND I THINK THAT THE
ADVANCEMENTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO MAKE, BECAUSE OF THE
COMMUNICATION RECEIVED REGARDING
EQUITY AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS, WHICH
YOU'RE A PART OF, NOTING THAT
ANY OF THE BONDS HAVE TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF EQUITY, I BELIEVE
THAT THERE WAS A GREAT DEAL OF A
GREAT JOB DONE IN THAT
PARTICULAR AREA, AND I'D NOTE
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. THERE
WAS A QUESTION NUMBER SIX. DOES
THIS BILL ENHANCE EQUITY IN
SCHOOL FACILITY FUNDING? THE
COMMITTEE DID A GREAT JOB OF
SHOWING THE WAYS THAT THIS
PARTICULAR BOND HAS IMPROVED IN
COMPARISON TO LAST BONDS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THAT ISSUE,
BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING WHAT MY
COAUTHOR AND COLLEAGUE HAS SAID
IS THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THERE
ARE SOME SMALLER RURAL DISTRICTS
THAT, COULD FEEL DISADVANTAGED
IN COMPARISON, BUT THAT IS TO
SAY THAT THERE ARE LARGER
DISTRICTS THAT HAS A DEFINITE
NEED. YOU NOTED, ONE THAT HAS A
DEFINITE NEED AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE ONE STUDENT
BENEFIT AT THE EXPENSE OF
ANOTHER STUDENT. AND SO
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS, EQUITY
IS AT THE FOREFRONT AND IT RUNS
THROUGH IT, IT'S IMPROVED. AND I
THINK THIS DOES A GREAT JOB OF
BALANCING THE FACT THAT
WEALTHIER DISTRICTS HAVE A NEED
FOR, STUDENTS WITHIN THEIR
DISTRICT THAT ARE IN GREAT NEED,
AND THEN SO DO OUR ROLLS. AND SO
I THINK IT BALANCES THAT NEED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND I JUST
HAVE ONE FOLLOW UP QUESTION. AND
THIS HAS TO DO WITH, WHENEVER I
SEE INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS I
OFTEN THINK ABOUT THE LABOR
STANDARDS AND THE EQUITY
STANDARDS AND TOO OFTEN WE DON'T
SEE THESE DOLLARS AS
MULTIPLIERS, MEANING WE HAVE
THIS MONEY TO HELP BALANCE SORT
OF THE SOCIOECONOMIC DISPARITIES
IN TERMS OF FACILITIES. BUT WE
COULD ALSO USE THAT MONEY TO
REACH SOME OF THOSE ADULT ED
STUDENTS TO COME IN TO DO THE
ACTUAL WORK ON THE FACILITIES.
CAN YOU SAY MORE ABOUT THE LABOR
AND EQUITY STANDARDS THAT ARE
CONNECTED? I DID SEE THAT YOU
SAW A NUMBER OF THE TRADES HERE
IN SUPPORT, BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
WORKFORCE EQUITY PIECE AND WHO'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE DOING THIS
WORK? AND HAS THAT BEEN TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION? YES,
ABSOLUTELY. SO, THE POINT SYSTEM
THAT, THAT I AND OUR JOINT
AUTHORS HAVE HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT, IT GIVES ADDITIONAL POINT
PREFERENCE TO PROJECTS THAT
INVOLVE PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS. THAT IS THE REASON
WHY THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS. WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT, YOU KNOW, IF WE
ARE GOING TO BE, BUILDING, OUR
SCHOOLS, FIXING OUR SCHOOLS WITH
A SKILLED AND TRAINED LABOR THAT
WE WANT TO, SUPPORT AND
INCENTIVIZE THAT BY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR, FOR
THOSE PROPOSED PROJECTS. THANK
YOU. AND I APPRECIATE THAT. I
THINK THAT IS A MODEL. AND I
THINK THERE ARE SOME ADVANCES IN
THE WAYS THAT UNIONS ARE ARE
BUILDING THESE AGREEMENTS TO
BRING IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. LIKE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED, EMANCIPATED FOSTER
YOUTH, SINGLE PARENTS. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE SEE THAT
KIND OF LANGUAGE AND THE
PARTNERSHIP SO THAT ALL OF THE
COMMUNITIES AND ALL OF THE
DISTRICTS GET A CHANCE TO
MULTIPLY THESE DOLLARS. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING, THANK YOU, SENATOR.
LET'S GO NOW TO SENATOR GLAZER.
I HAVE A COMMENT, NOT A
QUESTION, THE NEEDS ARE GREAT,
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED THEM IN YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY, AND I'M
CERTAINLY PLEASED TO JOIN WITH
YOU AND ADVANCING THIS BILL FOR
THOSE THOSE CLEAR REASONS, AND I
KNOW THESE MEASURES ARE A RESULT
OF COMPROMISES WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT OPINIONS FROM A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PLACES. BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO NOTE MY
DISAPPOINTMENT THAT OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ARE
NOT INCLUDED IN THIS BOND. THAT
IS, AS A POINT OF DEEP
DISAPPOINTMENT, GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THEIR FACILITIES ARE VERY,
VERY OLD. PLUMBING FAILING,
ELECTRICAL FAILING, LABS THAT
AREN'T SAFE. AND WE COULD GO ON
AND ON. AND I THINK THE EVIDENCE
THAT THOSE SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED TO YOU AND TO US ARE
PRETTY COMPELLING TO HAVE MADE
THE CASE THAT ANY KIND OF
COMPROMISE ON THIS EDUCATION
FACILITY BOND SHOULD HAVE
INCLUDED THOSE INSTITUTIONS. AND
I'LL I'LL CLOSE MY REMARKS WITH
THIS POINT, THEY CAN'T CONTINUE
TO HAVE THAT CIRCUMSTANCE AND
STILL HAVE A SAFE ENVIRONMENT
FOR OUR STUDENTS, THE LAST
STANDALONE BOND FOR THE THESE
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS WAS IN
2006, AND THEIR FACILITIES
AREN'T GETTING ANY YOUNGER. AND
THE WARNING TO ME AND I
HOPEFULLY TO YOU AND OTHERS HERE
ON THE, ON THE DAIS IS THAT,
WHO'S GOING TO PAY FOR THOSE
UPGRADES WHEN THEY HAPPEN? AND
IT'S GOING TO BE THE STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES IN THE FORM
OF TUITION INCREASES. THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN. AND I'M
SURE YOU AND OTHERS HERE ARE
AWARE THAT THE STATE
UNIVERSITIES ANNOUNCED EARLIER
THIS YEAR A 24% INCREASE IN
TUITION OVER THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS. AND I'M SURE NOBODY UP
HERE IS HAPPY ABOUT THAT AND
WOULD HAVE EVER VOTED FOR IT.
BUT WITHOUT STATE SUPPORT, WHAT
ARE THEY TO DO AND WHAT ARE THEY
TO DO WITH THESE FACILITIES THAT
ARE DECREPIT ON THEIR CAMPUSES
TODAY? IF THEY'RE NOT INCLUDED
IN BOND INVESTMENTS LIKE THE
BILL THAT'S BEFORE US? SO THAT'S
THAT'S NOT A GOOD SITUATION,
WHEN THESE INSTITUTIONS WERE
CREATED IN THE 1950S AND THE
1960S, WHO PAID FOR THOSE
FACILITIES? ALL OF CALIFORNIA
PAID FOR THOSE FACILITIES. THEY
DIDN'T PUT IT ON THE BACKS OF
THE STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WE ALL TOOK A RESPONSIBILITY TO
PAY FOR THESE HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS, BECAUSE WE KNEW
THERE HOW IMPORTANT THEY WERE TO
OUR PEOPLE. SO IT'S A STATE
INVESTMENT THAT IS SUSTAINED AND
BUILT AND SUSTAINED. THESE
INSTITUTIONS. AND I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US TO CONTINUE
THAT PROMISE. AND THAT
COMMITMENT AND NOT HAVE IT BE ON
THE BACKS OF STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AND THAT'S THE
POTENTIAL RESULT IF WE DON'T
GIVE IT OUR ATTENTION IN YEARS
TO COME, BECAUSE THOSE
INSTITUTIONS ARE GOING TO COME
BACK AND THEY'RE GOING TO
THEY'RE GOING TO DO THINGS.
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT IT IN
REVENUE BONDS. AND WHO'S GOING
TO PAY FOR THAT? THE STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES, THEY'RE
GOING TO DO OTHER BORROWING
SCHEMES. WHO'S GOING TO PAY FOR
THAT? IT'S THE STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. UNLESS THIS
LEGISLATURE IS PAYING ATTENTION
AND INTERVENES AND I KNOW IT'S
TOUGH. AND WHEN OPERATING
BUDGETS ARE UP AND DOWN, BUT
INVESTMENTS LIKE WITH THESE
BONDS IS WHAT CAN PROVIDE FOR
THAT. AND IF IT'S NOT HAPPENING
THIS YEAR, I HOPE THAT
CONSIDERATION WILL BE GIVEN BY
OUR GREAT LEADERS HERE TODAY, IN
FUTURE YEARS. BUT THAT'S THE
DISAPPOINTMENT. IT COMES,
THOUGH, IN A IN A VERY GOOD
MEASURE, A STRONG MEASURE THAT
WILL DO A LOT FOR K THROUGH 14.
AND THAT'S WHY I'M PLEASED TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GLAZER, SENATOR WILK.
WELL, MR. CHAIR, I THINK SENATOR
GLAZER TALKED ME OUT OF
SUPPORTING IT. NOT REALLY. I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS, YOU AND I
ALONG WITH SENATOR NEUMANN'S
SENATOR ON THE STATE ALLOCATION
BOARD, THE NEEDS ARE SO GREAT.
AND I KNOW WE'VE BEEN FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE FUNDS
TO DISPERSE, TO IMPROVE THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE'S LIVES. AND IT IS
ABOUT COMPROMISE. AND I THINK
YOU'VE DONE A WONDERFUL JOB. SO
I SEE THIS LIST FROM THE
OPPOSITION ON THAT IS ONE OF MY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND I WILL
TELL YOU, IT'S A SCHOOL
DISTRICT. FRANKLY, THAT PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T EVEN BE IN EXISTENCE.
WE HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THIS PARTICULAR REGION, AND
THEN WE HAVE SIX ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS, AND IT JUST
DOESN'T MAKE ECONOMIC SENSE. SO
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE WE OUGHT TO
LOOK AT DOWN THE ROAD IN TERMS
OF CONSOLIDATING DISTRICTS. BUT
THIS IS AS GOOD AS YOU'RE GOING
TO GET IN THIS KIND OF
ENVIRONMENT WITH ALL THE ALL THE
THINGS YOU HAVE TO BALANCE FROM
ALL THE COMPETING INTERESTS AND
HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOU TODAY. MR.
CHAIR, IF I MAY, PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THROUGH THE CHAIR, I
WANTED TO FIRST OF ALL, THANK
SENATOR GLAZER FOR NOT ONLY
CHAMPIONING THE SCHOOL BOND
CAUSE ON THE SENATE SIDE, BUT IN
MORE SPECIFICALLY CHAMPIONING
OUR UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
SYSTEM AND OUR CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. AND, YOU KNOW
, YOU'RE HITTING A REAL, TOUGH
SPOT IN MY HEART BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, I'VE, I'VE ALWAYS TRIED TO
BE A CHAMPION FOR OUR PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM. AND,
YOU KNOW, IDEALLY, I WOULD HAVE
LIKED TO SEE A HIGHER A BIGGER
SCHOOL BOND THAT WOULD HAVE
INCLUDED OUR UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. YOU KNOW, I'M A
PROUD CAL BEAR AND UCLA BRUIN
AND I YOU KNOW, I KNOW THAT LIKE
, LIKE SO MANY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, YOU KNOW, THE IMPACT
OF OUR UCS AND OUR CSU'S ARE
MUCH LARGER THAN JUST THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS THAT, THAT, THAT THE
TWO SYSTEMS COMBINED EDUCATE,
YEAR BY YEAR. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
I, YOU KNOW, I KNOW THAT THERE
WERE STRONG ARGUMENTS MADE IN
PARTICULAR FOR, NOT ONLY FOR THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE CHALLENGES
THAT ARE UCS AND CSU'S FACE, BUT
ALSO, YOU KNOW, THE DESIRE TO
HAVE STUDENT HOUSING FUNDING FOR
OUR UCS AND CSUS, YOU KNOW, I
MEAN, AN IDEAL WORLD.
ABSOLUTELY. WE SHOULD HAVE HAD
THAT IN THERE, BUT LIKE YOU
SAID, I MEAN, THIS IS A
COLLECTIVE, THE PRODUCT OF A
COLLECTIVE DISCUSSION OF HARD
CHOICES THAT HAD TO BE MADE. I
WANT TO, GIVE A CHANCE FOR OUR
CHAIR OF HIGHER EDUCATION. IF
YOU WANT TO ADD ANYTHING TO
THAT. I THANK YOU SO MUCH. JUST,
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR FOR
BRINGING THAT FORWARD. I KNOW
THAT THESE WERE VERY TOUGH
NEGOTIATIONS AND DISCUSSIONS ON
THE COMPROMISE. AND IN TERMS OF
THE NEEDS OF THE UC AND CSU
SYSTEM IS I THINK SENATOR GLAZER
MENTIONED GOING FORWARD, WE'LL
BE LOOKING TO HOW WE CAN SEE AND
ASSESS THE NEEDS AND TO REALLY
LOOK AT THE FUTURE BONDING
CAPACITY AS WELL. I KNOW THAT
THERE'S REVENUE BONDS AVAILABLE,
BUT I KNOW THAT, WHEN WE LOOK AT
THIS PARTICULAR BOND IS
MURATSUCHI HAS MENTIONED IT'S
ORIGINALLY WE WERE LOOKING AT 14
BILLION AND NOW THE 10 BILLION.
AND AT THIS COMPROMISE TO REALLY
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS, I THINK
THIS IS, THE BEST CASE SCENARIO
AT THIS POINT. AND SO WE'D LOVE
TO CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE ON THE
ISSUES THAT WE'VE ALREADY LAID
OUT HERE. AND ON OUR K 14 SCHOOL
FACILITIES BOND. BUT POINT'S
WELL TAKEN. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GLAZER, FOR YOUR ADVOCACY AND
LEADERSHIP, IN TERMS OF A CSU
AND, UC SYSTEM AND WITH YOUR
MEASURE AS WELL. SO THANK YOU.
AND I KNOW, SENATOR CIOBO, YOUR
COMMENT. YES. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. SO OUT OF CURIOSITY,
BECAUSE I DID UP UNTIL THIS YEAR
WAS ON BUDGET ONE AND HAVE
HEARD, TOO MUCH CONCERN. THE
NEEDS FOR THE CSUS AND THE UC.
SO MY QUESTION LIES INTO, ONE
HOW AND WHO DECIDED THAT THE 10
BILLION RATHER THAN THE 14. AND
NUMBER TWO, WHY DID WE NOT
INCLUDE THE UCS AND THE CSU'S
CONSIDERING, ALL THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED AND
HAVE BEEN ON RECORD WITH THE, IN
COMMITTEES. THANK YOU, SENATOR,
FOR THE QUESTION, REALLY, IT WAS
ABOUT BONDING CAPACITY,
RECOGNIZING WE ARE IN A
CHALLENGING YEAR AND, NONE OF
THIS MONEY IS FREE. RIGHT? AND
SO THERE IS A DEBT SERVICE
OBLIGATION RELATED TO THAT. AND
SO THROUGH LEADERSHIP, IT WAS
DETERMINED. AND LEADERSHIP AND
THE GOVERNORS, IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE,
THAT, 20 BILLION WOULD BE AN
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT FOR BONDS
THIS YEAR. AND SO THERE ARE TWO
BONDS GOING FORWARD, THERE WERE
THOUGHT OF THREE HOUSING CLIMATE
AND SCHOOL FACILITIES, BECAUSE
OF THE BUDGET WINDS THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE AGREEMENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE, HOUSING DID
GET A RESTORATION OF FUNDS. AND
SO WE WENT FORWARD WITH TWO
BONDS, CLIMATE AND EDUCATION.
BOTH BONDS TOTALED WELL MORE
THAN $20 BILLION. RIGHT. AND SO,
AS NOTED, THERE WAS A, YOU KNOW,
$15 BILLION BOND OR $14 BILLION
BOND ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE. THERE
WAS, I THINK, A $16 BILLION BOND
ON THE SENATE SIDE THAT INCLUDED
HIGHER ED. AND THEN THEN THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE. THERE WAS ABOUT
20 BILLION WORTH OF CLIMATE
BONDS. AND THEN THERE WAS
ANOTHER, $15.5 BILLION OF
CLIMATE BONDS ON THE SENATE
SIDE. AND SO THROUGH THE FULL
NEGOTIATIONS, DETERMINING WHAT
WERE THE PRIORITIES AS IT
RELATES TO SCHOOL FACILITIES
AND, CLIMATE RESILIENCE FOR
CALIFORNIA, IT WAS DETERMINED A
$20 BILLION BOND. AND THAT
ALLOWED BOTH SIDES, BOTH PEOPLE
WORKING ON EACH BOND TO NARROW,
TO THE HIGHEST PRIORITY, AND AS
NOTED WHEN TALKING ABOUT THE UC
AND OUR CSU SYSTEM, THERE IS
DEFINITELY A GREAT NEED THERE,
BUT THERE'S ALSO A GREAT NEED IN
OUR K THROUGH 14 AND ENSURING
THAT WE START WITH K THROUGH 14,
WHICH REQUIRE EVERY YOUNG CHILD
IN CALIFORNIA TO GO THROUGH THAT
SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT THERE WAS
PROPER RESOURCES THERE, AND THEN
TACKLE THE UC, CSU REQUIREMENT
OR THE NEEDS ON THE NEXT TIME
AROUND. AND SO THAT'S WHERE THE
20 BILLION CAME ABOUT. AND THAT
WAS PART OF WHY THE DECISION,
WAS THERE WAS MADE THERE. GOOD.
SO IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS, WHEN
YOU FOLKS DECIDED TO PRIORITIZE
K-12 AND NOT THE UCS AND THE
CSU'S, WHAT WERE THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH REGARDS TO,
ADDRESSING THE CSU'S AND THE UCS
NEEDS IN THE FUTURE? WELL,
THERE'S THROUGH OUR NORMAL
BUDGET PROCESS. AND SO EVERYBODY
HAS THAT AS A WE KNOW IT'S A
PRIORITY. THE NEED HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED. AND AS WELL AS IN
FUTURE BOND CAPACITY, WHEN WE
DEAL WITH BOND ON SCHOOL
FACILITIES IN A FUTURE YEARS,
INCORPORATING ENSURE THAT
INCORPORATES UC, CSU BECAUSE
THEY WERE CUT OUT OF THE BONDS
THIS TIME AROUND. SO FOR MY
PART, LET ME ALSO EXPRESS MY
DISAPPOINTMENT IN THE FAILURE TO
INCLUDE HIGHER ED IN THIS BOND.
AND BUT TO BE CLEAR, THERE WAS A
NEGOTIATION, BUT THERE WAS A
VERY CLEAR CONSENSUS ON THE
SENATE SIDE THAT WE SHOULD
INCLUDE HIGHER EDUCATION. SO,
FIND, YOU KNOW, A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED. AND TO YOUR POINT,
AND TO SENATOR GLAZER'S POINT,
THOSE NEEDS NOT ONLY REMAIN,
THEY INTENSIFY OVER TIME. WE'LL
HAVE TO ADDRESS THEM, LET ME ASK
YOU A QUESTION TO THE WITNESSES
AND POINTING OUT THAT BY VIRTUE
OF THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS, IF
WE WERE TO AMEND THIS BILL
TODAY, IT WOULD EFFECTIVELY,
PRECLUDE THE ABILITY TO PUT THIS
ON THE BALLOT. YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT, RIGHT? AND YOU'RE OKAY
WITH THAT? THIS IS, BY ALL
INTENTS AND PURPOSES, NOT
AMENABLE, BILL, AT THIS POINT.
SO FROM FROM MY PART AND AS I
SAID BEFORE, OUR THE ISSUE THAT
WE TOOK IN LINWOOD, FOR EXAMPLE,
AND IT WASN'T AN EFFORT TO SAY
THAT WE WERE OPPOSING LA USD, IT
WASN'T THAT IT WAS WHAT HAPPENS
OFTENTIMES IN SMALL DISTRICTS,
EVEN WITH TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE,
IT BECOMES A MORE FIRST TO THE
TO THE APPLICATION. OH NO, I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. YOU'RE
VERY CLEAR. BUT BUT TO MAKE I
JUST WANT TO ASK YOU A QUESTION.
YES OR NO, IT IS IT IS AN
UNFORTUNATE TRUTH OF THE
MECHANICS OF THIS PROCESS THAT
IF WE WERE TO DECIDE TO AMEND
THIS BILL TODAY, IT WOULD MEAN
THAT WE COULD NOT MEET THE
DEADLINE TO PLACE THIS ON THE
BALLOT AS A PROPOSITION WHICH
MEANS WE'D WAIT ANOTHER TWO
YEARS, AT LEAST, TO MAKE THE
KINDS OF INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. RIGHT. AND I HEAR
YOU. SO I WOULD SAY TO THAT,
THAT, I WOULDN'T WANT TO SEE THE
BILL NOT MOVE FORWARD. WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR, AGAIN, IS, IS
ADDITIONAL NUANCE TO THE
APPROACH TO EQUITY TO ENSURE
THAT IT'S NOT FIRST COME, FIRST
SERVED, BUT IT IS IT IS NEED
BASED. AND AGAIN, IT'S NOT AN
EFFORT TO GET ALL THE MONEY FOR
THE SMALL DISTRICT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S A FAIR SHOT OF
GETTING THE FUNDING. SO I WOULD
SAY IN MY OPINION, NO, THAT I
THINK THAT THE BILL SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD. SO, OKAY. AND FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE. OH, SORRY. THANK
YOU. FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE,
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN UNCONVENTIONAL, SORRY,
THAT'S NOT A WORD UNCONVENTIONAL
ABOUT HOW THIS PROCESS HAS MOVED
FORWARD. SO WE THOUGHT WE THINK
IT COULD STILL BE POSSIBLE FOR
YOU TO AMEND IT, AND GET IT ON
THE BALLOT, I MEAN, YOU CAN
YOU'RE THE EXPERT. SO YOU COULD
TELL US OTHERWISE, BUT I THINK
MANY THINGS HAPPENED THAT
WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN. I
JUST TELL YOU OTHERWISE. SO THAT
IS THAT IS THE TRUTH. I MEAN,
YOU KNOW, IF WE WERE TO AMEND
THIS BILL TODAY, WE WOULD MISS
OUR DEADLINE. THAT IS CORRECT.
IT HAS TO BE IN PRINT 72 HOURS
BEFORE, AND JULY 3RD IS WASN'T
IT SUPPOSED TO BE DONE BY LAST
THURSDAY? DIFFERENT QUESTION.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT QUESTION.
THERE'S DEADLINES AND THEN
THERE'S FINAL FINALS, SO AGAIN I
APPRECIATE YOUR I JUST WANTED TO
POINT THAT OUT AND GET YOUR
INPUT. AND WHILE TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT I THINK YOUR OTHERWISE,
YOU KNOW, VERY VALID CONCERNS, I
GUESS I'LL MOVE ON FROM THERE.
SORRY JUST A FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR
WITH YOUR QUESTION. ACTUALLY
OKAY. BRIEFLY GO AHEAD. SO I
JUST WANT TO CONFIRM THAT YOUR
CONCERNS, YOUR OPPOSITION TO,
THIS PROPOSITION IS BASED ON THE
LANGUAGE AND THOSE THAT YOU
REPRESENT ARE BASED ON THE
LANGUAGE THAT WAS CURRENTLY,
PRINT IN PRINT AS OF LAST OR
SATURDAY. CORRECT? I MEAN, I CAN
SPEAK TO THAT. THAT'S CORRECT. I
MEAN, YOU'VE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
, WHICH IF WE WERE TO CONSIDER
THEM NOW, WE WOULD MISS THE
DEADLINE FOR THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE, WHICH WILL, YOU KNOW,
WILL TURN INTO THE PROPOSITION
ON THE BALLOT. AND THAT'S AN
UNFORTUNATE FACT, I DON'T KNOW.
GO AHEAD, SENATOR, JUST I MEAN,
PART OF THE PARADOX HERE IS
EVERYONE IS WORKING TO TRY TO
GET 100% CONSENSUS, EVEN TO THE
POINT OF TAKING ADVANTAGE OF AN
EXTENDED QUOTE UNQUOTE, EXTENDED
DEADLINE, STILL OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T
QUITE GET TO 100% CONSENSUS, BUT
NOW WE'RE UP AGAINST WEDNESDAY,
YOU KNOW, MIDNIGHT, AND IT'S
GOING TO BE EVERYTHING WE CAN DO
TO GET THIS PASSED WEDNESDAY,
MIDNIGHT OR WE GET NOTHING, I
MEAN, THAT'S JUST WHERE WE'RE
AT. BUT I JUST WANTED TO GIVE
THAT PERSPECTIVE ON REALITY. IT
DOESN'T MEAN ANYBODY SHOULD HAVE
STOPPED OPPOSING OR TRYING TO
GET WHAT THEY WANTED, BUT THESE
NEGOTIATIONS JUST GO RIGHT DOWN
TO THE TO THE WIRE SOMETIMES WE
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE. I THINK WE ALL DO. I DO AS
WELL. I JUST, I JUST WANT DID
NOT WANT TO LEAVE ANY AMBIGUITY,
YOU KNOW, WITH RESPECT TO THIS
CONVERSATION THAT THERE WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY IN THIS MOMENT TO
MAKE THE KINDS OF CHANGES YOU
PROPOSED FOR THIS BILL AND THIS
BALLOT MEASURE. SO HAVING HAVING
SAID THAT, LET ME SAY A FEW
THINGS IN RESPONSE TO SOME OF
YOUR CRITICISMS. YOU KNOW, LET
ME ALSO LET ME THANK PUBLIC
ADVOCATES AND EVERYBODY,
INCLUDING EVERYBODY ON YOUR
LIST, ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS,
FOR THEIR PASSIONATE ADVOCACY AS
IT RELATES TO, YOU KNOW, AGAIN,
YOUR VERY VALID CONCERNS, YOUR
ADMIRABLE CONCERNS AROUND EQUITY
IN SCHOOL FACILITY FUNDING. AS
SENATOR MURATSUCHI POINTED OUT,
SENATOR WILK, HE I WE SIT ON THE
STATE ALLOCATIONS BOARD. THERE'S
A MASSIVE BACKLOG AND THAT IS
WHAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS. AND
WE'D HAVE TO DO THAT SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER, LET ME ALSO
RESPECTFULLY, YOU KNOW, CONTEST
THE ASSERTION THAT THE CURRENT
SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. IT'S BEEN IN
PLACE SINCE 1998. IT'S ENJOYED
WIDESPREAD SUPPORT. IT'S NEVER
BEEN CONTESTED IN COURT, BUT THE
PROGRAM'S FRAMEWORK IS BUILT ON
PRINCIPLES OF EQUITY AND
FAIRNESS. AND OVER TIME, IT HAS
EVOLVED. IT'S BEEN UPDATED TO
BETTER SERVE CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
REGARDING THE PROPOSAL FOR A
SLIDING SCALE APPROACH. WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND TO COMMEND THE INTENT
TO FURTHER SUPPORT LOWER WEALTH
DISTRICTS, IF WE WERE TO
IMPLEMENT SUCH A DRASTIC
REDISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS, THAT'S
REALLY NOT FEASIBLE GIVEN OUR
CURRENT FINANCIAL CONSTRAINTS
THEREIN, THE NEED FOR THIS BOND.
AND SO THIS BILL OVERALL AND THE
BOND MEASURE, WHICH IT WILL
CREATE, ENDEAVORS TO STRIKE WHAT
I REGARD AS AN IMPORTANT BALANCE
BY IMPLEMENTING A SLIDING SCALE,
WHICH INCREASES STATE GRANT
AMOUNTS BASED ON A COMBINATION
OF A DISTRICT'S ABILITY TO
GENERATE LOCAL FUNDS AND THE
PERCENTAGES OF LOW INCOME FOSTER
CARE AND ENGLISH LEARNER
STUDENTS AS CONTAINED IN THE
LANGUAGE. AND THIS BALANCED
APPROACH PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT TO HÌNH DISTRICTS WHILE
MAINTAINING A SUSTAINABLE AND
BROADLY SUPPORTED FUNDING MODEL
STATEWIDE. FURTHER THE EXISTING
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP ASSISTANCE
WITHIN THE SFP IS DESIGNED TO
AID LOW WEALTH OR LOW WEALTH
DISTRICTS WHICH CONTINUE TO FACE
CHALLENGES, AS POINTED OUT, IN
GENERATING LOCAL FUNDS, AND
THERE ARE PROVISIONS
SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS THOSE
NEEDS. AND TO THAT END, A
CRUCIAL COMPONENT OF THE MEASURE
IS THE INCLUSION OF A NEW
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE INITIATIVE.
AND MR. HARDY POINTED OUT, MANY
SCHOOLS LACK EITHER THE
RESOURCES OR THE EXPERTISE TO
COMPETE, AND THIS LEVERAGES A
RECENT FEDERAL GRANT, BUT IT
WILL PROVIDE IN-PERSON AND
ONGOING REGIONAL SUPPORT TO AS
MANY PRIORITY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AS POSSIBLE, PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHICH HAVE NOT PREVIOUSLY
PARTICIPATED IN SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM EFFORTS BEFORE AND ARE
THEREFORE UNLIKELY TO HAVE THE
KIND OF EXPERTISE THAT
PARTICIPATION GENERALLY ENTAILS.
THIS TARGETED SUPPORT WILL
ENSURE THAT THESE DISTRICTS CAN
SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATE THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AND
EVENTUALLY ACCESS THE FUNDS THAT
THEY'LL NEED TO MODERNIZE AND
IMPROVE THEIR FACILITIES. AND SO
AS A AS A JOINT AUTHOR, YOU
KNOW, IT'S CLEARLY, MY STRONG
VIEW THAT AB 247 REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD AND A
NECESSARY ONE AT THIS TIME,
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE STATE'S
FISCAL CONDITION. SO I DO
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE INPUT, AND
I'D ASK, THIS, THIS MANY HEADED
BEAST THAT ARE THE JOINT AUTHORS
FROM THE ASSEMBLY. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE, PLEASE DO SO. WELL,
AGAIN, THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR
ALL OF YOUR WORK ON THIS
MEASURE, MR. CHAIR, I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH YOUR YOUR CLOSING
COMMENTS THAT, YOU KNOW, LIKE WE
OFTEN SAY IN THE LEGISLATURE,
DON'T LET THE PERFECT GET IN THE
WAY OF THE GOOD, THIS IS NOT
COMPLETELY WHAT PUBLIC ADVOCATES
WAS ASKING FOR, BUT IT ADDRESSES
MANY OF THEIR CONCERNS. I KNOW
THAT THEIR LEGAL ANALYSIS
FOCUSED ON THE SERRANO VERSUS
PRIEST. AND, YOU KNOW, HAVING
FUNDING BASED ON LOCAL PROPERTY,
YOU KNOW, VALUES THIS, THAT THIS
BILL GOES BEYOND SERRANO VERSUS
PRIEST BECAUSE OF THE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP PROGRAMS. I DON'T WANT
TO GET TOO MUCH INTO THE WEEDS
ON THAT. BUT THE BOTTOM LINE,
WHAT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE IS THAT
THIS IS A EQUITY CENTERED
MEASURE THAT PRIORITIZES
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP DISTRICTS,
PRIORITIZES THE ADDITIONAL STATE
MATCHING DOLLARS FOR THE
SOCIOECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
DISTRICTS ON TOP OF ALL THE
GREAT THINGS THEY ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY THINGS THAT WE NEED IN
THIS MEASURE. AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE ANY OTHER WORDS FROM
THE JOINT AUTHORS? THIS IS YOUR
CHANCE. I THINK THE SAME. I
THINK, TO ECHO THE REMARKS OF MY
COLLEAGUE, IS THAT THIS REALLY
DOES ADDRESS A LOT OF THE EQUITY
CONCERNS TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
GREATER SUPPORT FOR OUR
DISADVANTAGED AND LOWER WEALTH
COMMUNITIES, AND I APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE SO
FAR BETWEEN BOTH OF OUR HOUSES
TO ENSURE WE HAVE A SCHOOL
FACILITY, BONDS THAT SUPPORT
STUDENTS AND ENSURES THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
PROVIDE A FIRST CLASS EDUCATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR COMMENTS. I THINK WE KNOW
THE NEED IS GREATER THAN WHAT IS
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE, BUT THE
WORK AND EFFORTS TO GET TO THIS
POINT HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS, AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
COMMENTS AND URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR, I'VE GOT A
MOTION. SENATOR GLAZER, MADAM,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
1AB2 47 MURATSUCHI MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE.
OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI CORTEZ. I
CORTEZ I GLASER. GLASER. I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
WILK. I WILK I THANK YOU. THE
MEASURE PASSES SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. THANK YOU EVERYBODY. THANK
YOU TO STAFF, ESPECIALLY TO MR.
IAN JOHNSON FOR HIS VERY GOOD
WORK ON THIS MEASURE, THIS
MEETING OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED. GOOD
JOB. THANK YOU.